sobem 20 e hoje vou ensinar como fazer
esta michigan
eu penso que eu me engane não for e
qualquer coisa muito pior se a um pneu
usado nas groupme criar isto e eu estava
sendo desmatada que deixar o tutorial
muito bem feito para que vocês consigam
fazer também e eu sei que vocês vão
pensar vai isto é muito bonito e levarem
mas é muito difícil fazer mas não é
porque estavam parece difícil por ser
grande mas basicamente é só colar turnos
estarão em três vezes ou mais resistente
do que as outras que têm feito porque
por cada tubo é feito quando três folhas
de papel e se aumenta bastante a
existência dela e como eu fiz mais nos
tempos que por um lado fico mais fora só
com um laço mais forte o gatinho
tradicional não funcionar não conseguiu
aguentar então eu criei um outro gatilho
que é muito muito muito mais forte é que
consegue aguentar a força deste plástico
é claro que eu esqueça você consegue
comprar esse laço que as cantorias com a
pergunta o nome portões posição é só
você sempre estiveram lá chegar lá e
plantar com elásticos grandes que contê
lá estiverem gantz o poder em muitos
clientes e claro esquecer de usar óculos
de proteção
é isso então vamos lá
para começar tem que rolar uma folha com
se fosse uma rifa caso vocês não
conseguirão fazer isso direito vou
deixar uma inflexão onde ensina a fazer
isso mas foi ar passa o país
para fazer um tubo cidade de três folhas
de papel e uma cola eu vou usar uma cola
é branca e uma cola teve a ou então uma
cola para a madeira
vocês podem usar aquela escola escolares
líquidas tambaqui
depois de colocar tem que pular as três
folhas a volta de rifa que vocês fizeram
inicialmente
[Música]
cândida que eu vou em orlando foi um
cola do lado a outro por aumentar assim
a existência dos tubos
para facilitar a aprendizagem e fiz
alguns temas em papel que o prejuízo é
corrigir bebidas e a posição exata dos
tubos
[Música]
o jantar os componentes de uma cola
quinta e só pode ser esta collor
primeiro lançado uma grande quantidade
ou seja estar numa grande superfície de
contato entre os tubos para aguentar a
opção do elástico grande e também a
questão do oscar rápido e ser mais
barato é então é melhor vocês usarem uma
cópia
para que à medida que o col os tubinhos
para fazer empunhadura eu vou sempre
trocando elogios ligeiramente para a
esquerda quer e fica assim maio
inclinado e não o rei
[Música]
corta se produziu no ângulo de 45 gramas
marquei os centímetros da esquerda para
a direita e depois marca quando vai
ficar o tubo de dos cintos
ponham colo entre as marcações e cole o
tubo de dois sentidos
a marca e cintos da esquerda para a
direita começando a contar do tubo de
dos centros
depois de marcarem por não cola e cola
em um tubo inteiro mas muita atenção
vocês têm que caminhar o tubo grande do
sul turvo de duas centenas para isso
vocês têm que colocar uma rifa do modo
que estou a mostrar
[Música]
agora utilizar de dois turbos tempo
definido uma rifa servirá para juntar os
dois tubos foi um pouco de cola uma das
partes da rifa encaixe com um tubo à
medida que vocês vão encaixando o tubo
por fifa
pq irlando uma das partes para espalhar
banheiro cola
deixem ficar um pouco e depois em caixa
o outro lado não faz um produto seguida
como eu fiz que não ficou tão bem como
vocês podem ver para depois destacar
como um tubo grande em que a conexão tem
que ficar mais no mínimo um lugar se
inalado ou seja se vocês fizerem uma
linha na perpendicular vai passar a mãe
da empreendedora
para fazer um peptídeo vão precisar de
fazer uma rifa cheiro muito mais fina
que as outras
então mas como vocês vão fazer uma rifa
normal só que antes de vocês colarem com
fita vou ter que lutar um triângulo e
depois prender com fita parte que sobrou
depois cortar a parte mais frágil
montanha rifa de modo a fazer mais ou
menos 11 com as dimensões mostradas aqui
agora as menções em mais ou menos
aproximado a cair
para fazer guarda mação sardoal uma rifa
normal seria parte mais frágil foi um
cola nessa parte e enrolem modo que
encaixa assim um tubo pro baixo do vídeo
depois moldem até ficar lhe a parte
final do turno
a seguir não precisa forçar a
empunhadura espaço onde foi normal e na
hora de vocês por em fita deixem ela um
pouco o pé por dentro permitindo assim
entre buchas pulmão
o curso foi formada com toda impunidade
era da arma isso vai aumentar bastante
resistência dela vocês vão verificar
isso logo quando acabar o argumento de
que comecem popular aquela parte de trás
e quando tiver sei que vocês têm
contornar tudo até o final verificar se
está tudo bem certinho e depois de verem
é só colar tudo sim procurando assim não
há de chegar àquela partida que vocês
vão ver que no vídeo
[Música]
para fazer o standard vocês vão precisar
de um conflito com mestria compra isto
numa loja de surf na gente tem um
político de bambu
se vocês não tiverem podem substituir
tudo em um pedaço de madeira ao cair
é importante que eles sejam resistentes
porque ele vai estar sujeito a muita
opção caí e você tem que mudar o modo
que eu caiba dentro do tubo do papel
vamos marcar em cumprimento do palito e
adicionem mais dois cintos e corda e
partir dessa marca
além dos poucos do picolé como indicada
em seguida e colhem o pistão
[Música]
juntos 3 campinhos modo a fazer uma
coluna para juntar o suíço usar a super
cola super cola especial para a madeira
então esta parte envolve maneiras de
usar a mesma cola e vocês podem usar o
outro super cola o tema ainda ok
quando em coluna por veicular sejam que
fica uma pequena distância entre a parte
cristã ea coluna espaço está reservado
para colocar o elástico ou cubillas
ticos eu vou usar um elástico grande
comprando companhia quando eu disse
inicialmente
aí você tem que ter muita atenção nesta
parte para que cola não toca no elástico
porque isto caro vai entregar 40 88
centímetros e cola e outros dois normais
1.253 tem que ficar no meio
[Música]
passa um orifício políticos quatro
centímetros a um centímetro da margem
a ação mesmo difícil nestes dois
pontinhos em que o edifício de um lado
conhecida como difícil do outro lado ou
seja tem que estar na linha
[Música]
os gastos três pontinhos modo que os
cargos muito papel mas não gastem mais
pra não ficar folgado que aí quando você
se encaixarem e ficaram assim já mais ou
menos estava para juntar as duas partes
ela vai cair se usar um efeito com um
clique ou seja pelo sindler ano
[Música]
e para que essa pesquisa não salto fora
vocês têm goulart qual ele um lado
espero que sei que depois colhem do
outro lado um colo perto do eixo
encaixem dentro do tubo do papel para
que eu cortei ligeiramente a que o
pallet minho cam dali solto em um corta
mas a mãe de 45 graus
vejam como funciona o pt tem um projeto
e qual é mais ou menos 45 centímetros
tem que ser ligeiramente maior do que o
piso aqui é porque vai ficar mais
resistentes vocês quiserem maior e podem
abusar o mesmo aqui na escola quanto
mais melhor
e aí está para ficar sujeito a muita
atenção uma vez que vai celular com a
ficar encaixado é para o bichão comentar
a existência da arma porém o super cola
nesta parte
eu tenho que lamentar a existência da
arma uma vez que é que o pistão vai
embater com velocidade então é uma zona
que vai estragar com o tempo
antes de colocar um elástico na arma
vocês têm que usar óculos de proteção
mesmo não estando disparar o eu acho que
pode curtir e e disparado para trás o
cae
então é isso e também estou fazendo esta
partida para nos mostrar que o que
entrei no final por ser feitar mas
aquela pequena psl quadrada no bric
ajuda para melhorar o sistema se fica
muito mais eficiente
terminada a parte mais difícil está na
hora de fazer crone o terminal para
especular um tubo nesta parte de baixo
mas um cubo branco gera - para agendar
uma parte a outra precisar de ter
morrido fira extremidades movem e cobrem
do modo indicado vídeo
[Música]
agora vou começar a fazer o par dos
portos para as balas escutei que duas
faixas com quatro gols 55 largura usa
uma caixa de isolado você pode usar você
acha que no anúncio do achas que é um
cartãozinho assim fininho mas é mais ou
menos resistentes
agora o comprimento vai entender que o
vosso gosto vocês fizeram um carregador
grande ou pequeno e distância entre as
balas do shape extintos agora vocês
podem variar o meu
foi a quarta fita está na altura de
fazerem mais dois ou três tubos este
tubos ao contrário dos primeiros são
feitos só com duas folhas
cópia em pedacinhos de 4,5 centímetros
mas atenção tem que fazer corte de
banheiro e só que não posso ficar assim
e aí é único pois vai dar problema na
hora de passar porque o espaçamento
específico aos pedacinhos neuzinha
estressados
uma coisa muito importante pois vocês
terminar esta série fita tem que passar
super cola em todas as partes além dos
tubinhos ao cair do lado e do outro o
que não vai entregar muito fácil nem
faça um circo carregador e depois
procure um prato que seja ligeiramente
maior que o diâmetro dessa filha quando
encontrarem tamanho certo então podem
sempre usar um compasso marca não foi da
população e no final no código
corte um pedaço de um tubo do modo que
quando colocado na parte inicial
conhecido como parte inicial do tubo de
cima passando os cortes na particular de
modo a formar uma água
o espaço tem ser suficiente para
permitir o encaixe e agora fazer um
pequeno detalhe que na verdade não sei
separar vencer armou para ajudar agarrá
la melhor
na teoria mas sim fazer por fica
bastante bonita e bastante fácil de
fazer para isso o cenário do grupo dass
popular e é o mesmo que acusa a idéia é
caixa do lado e depois de cortarem com
as medidas de que o indicado está
inteiro tirará alguns passinhos tirar
uns passinhos circular para isso usa o
véu para nos darmos vocês podem usar uma
tampa de uma garrafa quando tenta ficar
com ela em cima do carro sem atenção
para não colar no primeiro tubo no
primeiro turno quem ficasse ficado
elásticos em nada incluir o seu livro
funcionamento
após passar feita pela abertura conecta
em extremidades usando cola porque fica
não fica dançar conta e risco dos índios
tupi mg nico e colhem modo hospital
senna não vou tentar uma pega um suporto
vai para a frente seja um em pé
4 uma folha 10 pudessem filtros nem
valem como se fosse uma rifa plena
confiança e móveis de modo a fazer ao
possível com uma agulha nessa uma idade
foi grande
dobre quarta extremidades modo que
fiquem as duas ao mesmo nível e encaixe
naquela rifa que fizeram mais ou menos
uma agulha aprendam com fita para ficar
mais bonito eu vou encaixar líquidos
tubinhos permite
[Música]
só no final do vídeo fiquei bastante
contente e isso porque porque o be pede
a abordar naquela parte do cartão e não
tenha pensado isso foi pura só toque ea
chico muito vai se usar a arma
vou colar pega e ainda pega nem sempre
um silenciador só que eu não tenho vídeo
mas vai acrescentar um silenciador é só
fazer um tubo que seja ligeiramente
maior
o tucano a cair e depois é só coar o
tutorial não poderia ficar completo
mostrar como fazer os bairros para isso
você tem que marcar quatro tentos do
lado três tentos do outro ontem os
pontos cortem e envolvem de park maior
quando a parte mais pequena mas não
resolvem ter um final vai junto em
cortar sim do modo inclinado fica assim
mike um triângulo
aí essa parte que fica fora se maicon
bava é para ajudar a fixar a bala dentro
do carregador
[Música]
então e só os carros o fim os
espertinhos tal se você tiver alguma
sugestão de algum projeto que parece
impossível pra vocês podem deixar nos
comentários que o vai ter de fazer e
quando consigo fazer a auto você pra
vocês é impossível eu fiquei contente é
esse então pronto até a próxima
champions e é